Any questions on the quiz?
Two Two weeks after that is the third
quiz.
I'm still wrestling with the final exam
and but there will be an online version
and if you want to take it physically,
there'll be a physical version. So
either way you would be able you know,
so if you want to travel, go ahead and
make those plans because you can take
the exam online if you need to, you
know, from somewhere else.
But um
more details on that to follow.
So today we're going to continue our
discussion. Yes.
It'll be added to your on both. They'll
be combined for the total score.
Now, but ultimately I will check to see
if the average scores are widely
different then obviously I have to
figure out something to do, but usually
they're not. So that no.
So let's talk about pricing, right?
So today we're going to talk about what
the essence of a cheap stock on a
pricing basis is. I want you to think
like an investor. We're now in the
pricing world. What are you looking for?
Something that's cheap that doesn't
deserve to be cheap. Okay?
So I want you to tell me what
combination you'd like to find in a
stock for it to be a cheap stock for you
on a pricing basis.
So I'm going to give you five choices.
They're all low PE stocks. So I've made
that remain. The first one is high
growth, high risk, high return equity.
So the low PE is good, the high growth
is good,
the high return equity is good, but the
high risk, you don't want that, right?
So I want you to think about the
combination where everything is in your
favor.
You want to try? What's the Which one
would you pick?
So I shall high growth, low risk, high
return equity. So it'll be D,
right? I want you to start thinking that
way with every multiple. Today we're
going to go through the process of
figuring out what those variables are
with every multiple so that you can find
that combination.
And if you use Capital IQ, it's not you
know how easy it is to screen now. You
basically look for stocks with low PE,
high growth, low risk. Maybe nothing
will show up with your initial screens,
but then you can play with the screens
to see what shows up.
95% of active investing, that's all they
do. It's screening.
Finding the right screens then is
critical because if you do the right
screens, obviously you're going to get
the companies you wanted to get in that
final screen.
Second
One of the multiples we're also going to
talk about is the revenue multiple.
EV to sales, more consistent multiple.
Let's assume you are comparing revenue
multiples across retail firms.
Remember low multiple is better, high
multiple is worse. But if you just look
at the level of multiples, which of
these three group of firms
would you expect to trade at the lowest
multiple of revenues? Which would look
cheap if you just pick based on EV to
sales? Yeah.
And tell me why discount retailers are
going to look cheap.
Because you take a discount retailer,
they'll have huge revenues, but you take
a Costco or a Walmart, they won't look
If you look at the EV to sales, they'll
look cheap to you.
Why? Because the revenues are going to
be huge, the EV is going to be much
lower relative to revenues. They're not
cheap companies, cheap relative revenues
because you get low margins. Luxury
retailers will always look expensive
because EV to sales are going to be
higher.
So already you can see, if you're
comparing EV to sales ratios across
companies, you need to look at the
margins of these companies and find a
way to control for those differences.
So today we're going to introduce ways
of controlling for differences that go
beyond the storytelling, which is what a
lot of equity research analysts do.
So let's move back to where I left you
in the packet. I was talking about I
think
We're talking about uh
playing Moneyball.
You remember I left you with this table
of what PE ratios look like for US
companies. Current PE, trailing PE,
forward PE.
Two big messages. One is these
distributions are not symmetric. What
does that mean? The average is going to
get overstated because all of the
outliers are big positive numbers.
Second, we talked about bias. Remember
what the bias was?
Sophia.
Start with positive earnings, which
means I lose 3,600 of my firms with
current PE and then when I look for
forward PE, I lose even more firms
because I can't get the expected
earnings.
I've been doing these this that
histogram you saw on the previous page.
I've been doing this starting I think in
1995 was the first year I did it. For
the first decade,
I did it just for US stocks. Not because
I was US-centric, but because at that
time NYU did not have a database you
could go on. So I used to buy my own
data from Value Line. Came in a CD.
That's how how long ago it was. You put
in your computer, down and it was just
US companies.
And then I would take this graph to
Mumbai and I'd show this graph of US
stock PE ratio distributions and an
analyst in the audience, usually a
grizzled 55-year-old Indian analyst
would put up his hand and say, "It
doesn't look anything like that in
India."
I said, "Anything like what?"
The peak to the left, the tail to the
right. That's very US. It doesn't look
How do you know?
Gut feeling.
And after the fifth gut feeling
response, I said, "I need to look at our
non-Indian companies." So when this guy
guy says gut feeling, I can bring out
the actual distribution.
So starting about 20 years ago, I have
expanded my estimation of multiples
beyond US stocks. Now I do it for all
global stocks. So this start of 2025,
this is what PE ratios look like around
the globe.
So there's the US blue.
The red is the global distribution. The
two look alike. I can't tell them apart.
They both have the peak to the left, the
tail to the right. In every single part
of the world, the peak is to the left,
the tail is to the right. This is not
just a US phenomenon, it's a PE ratio
phenomenon.
Doesn't mean the PE ratios are the same
in every part of the world. In fact, if
you look across the subregions that I've
broken the world into, and you look at
the median PE and let's say you're a
global investor and you want to send
your money where the PE ratios are
lowest.
Where is all your money being invested?
It's the cheapest part of the world at
least on 2020.
Eastern Europe and Russia and good luck
on that one, right? Because there's a
reason they trade at low PEs, which is
high risk, right?
What's the most expensive market in the
world?
India.
You know how much heat I got for just
making this factual statement a month
and a half ago? I said India is the most
expensive market. I was accused of being
unpatriotic, you know. I said, "I'm not
even an Indian citizen. You can't accuse
me of being unpatriotic." I wasn't
dumping on India. I just said this is a
fact.
And there, if you were to give a
defense, what would your defense be for
why India trades at the highest PE
ratio?
The India story, right? With all of its
dimensions.
A billion 1.3 billion, we're the next
China. That's
You see, the problem with storytelling
is you can take the lowest PE and
explain it away with Whereas, the
highest PE and explain it away with
growth. We have to find a better way of
controlling for differences.
But, the first place to start is with
the data.
Let's stay with this data analysis.
I looked at the price-to-book ratios
around the world. Again, I looked at all
companies, did the I find it useful to
just break companies down and look
across the world. And if you look at
price-to-book ratios across the world,
the cheapest part of the world actually
is again Eastern Europe and Russia.
Welcome. And
there's Latin America.
There's Japan.
And then, some parts of the world stocks
trade at much higher price-to-book
ratios. The reason I bring this up is
there's this rule of thumb in investing
that if a stock trades at less than book
value, it's cheap, right? If you adopted
that rule in Latin America, half the
market will end up in your portfolio.
That's not my definition of cheap.
But, until you look at the data, you
fall for these rules of thumb.
And in fact, that's exactly I think this
is the best use for this data is
whenever somebody comes at you with a
rule of thumb, just pull the data out
and say, "How can that be cheap?"
Now, over the last 30 years, I've been
unfortunate enough to be on panels with
private equity investors. And if you
think about people who are shallow
pricers,
private equity investors are usually at
They use rules of thumb like six times
EBITDA is cheap. Says who?
Some drunk banker in the late '70s
probably invented this as he left his
office. Six times EBITDA is cheap. And
it gets passed down generation through
generation.
In 2010, if you told me six times EBITDA
is cheap, half the market was trading at
less than six times EBITDA.
Could six times EBITDA be cheap? Maybe
in 2025, but not if you're in Europe or
Japan.
You see where I'm going, right?
We Why are we using absolute number
rules of thumb? Statistically, what's a
good rule of thumb?
Take the 25th percentile, right? Don't
make up a number. Go to This is not
pricing. It's not your view, my view.
You're saying it's cheap relative to the
market. Why not let the data tell you
what In the '60s, your excuse is this is
too much work.
What's the excuse anymore?
When you see analysts talking about
average PE for a sector and making up
rules of thumb, my response is
just look at the data. Why do you need a
rule of thumb when the data is right
there and you can let the data drive
what you should be doing.
So, define, describe. Let's talk about
analyze.
My task here is to answer two questions.
You come to me with a multiple. But,
first I need to tell you what variables
affect this multiple. What are the
things that drive this multiple? And I'm
going to give you a very simple device
for backing out the variables. And I'll
give you a preview.
The PE ratio for a company is determined
by three variables, only three. It's
cost of equity, it's expected growth in
earnings, and it's payout ratio. And
I'll back up why the those three
variables show up.
And with every other multiple, I'm going
to be able to say these are the three,
these are the four, these are the five
variables.
Second, I need to tell you how as those
variables change, the PE ratio will
change. Let's take PE you know, the
multiple will change. Let's take PE
ratio. I said it was affected by growth,
cost of equity, which is indirectly
equity risk,
and payout ratio, which is indirectly
measure of quality of investment. As
growth increases, holding all else
constant, what should generally happen
to PE ratios?
Go up or go down?
They should
go
High growth
higher PE, right?
Holding all else constant, if I increase
just the risk in a company, what should
happen to the PE ratio?
Then, they will go down, right?
And holding all else constant, if you
can pay out more of your earnings and
deliver the same growth rate, which is a
higher return equity, your PE ratio
should go up again.
We're going to do that with every
multiple, because without doing it,
we're lost, right? Because we don't know
what to control for and how it will
change our multiples.
So, here's the device I use to back out
what drives the multiple.
Take a multiple, price-to-book ratio.
What kind of multiple is it? An equity
multiple? An enterprise value multiple?
What is price-to-book?
And what is it that makes it an equity
multiple?
Price.
Price per share and the book value is
shareholders' equity, book value of
equity. Price-to-book is an equity
multiple. Here's what I'm going to do to
determine what it is that drives the
price-to-book ratio.
I'm going to go back to the simplest
equity valuation model that I can think
of. It's called the Gordon growth model.
In the Gordon growth model, the value of
a stock is the expected dividend next
year divided by cost of equity minus
growth rate in the denominator.
Why simple? It keeps the algebra simple.
And my algebra is not that strong, so I
don't want to make this multi-equation.
In an equation in algebra, you're
allowed to divide both sides by a
constant?
Yeah, it still stays an equation. So,
what I'm going to do is going to divide
both sides of the dividend discount
model with the earnings with the book
value of equity.
The left side will then become
price-to-book.
The right side, dividing earnings by
book value gives me what?
That's return on equity.
The price-to-book ratio for a company is
determined by four variables. It's cost
of equity, it's expected growth rate,
it's payout ratio, and it's return on
equity.
What does that mean?
If I come to you with a cheap stock,
let's say I'm a naive, you know, stock
broker. I say, "This stock is cheap. It
trades at half of book value." All you
need to do is ask me four questions.
What's the expected growth rate in
earnings? Most of the time, what's the
answer going to be?
It's negative, the company's shrinking.
Hang up the phone.
Second, you would ask me, "How risky is
this company?"
You don't have to ask beta This is not
intrinsic valuation.
It's an incredibly risky company. It's
in Venezuela. You hang up the phone
again.
Third question you need to ask me is
what kind of return on equity does this
company have? And most of the time, if
it's a stock trading at half of book
value,
it delivers a return on equity well
below the cost of equity, maybe 3, 4,
5%.
Most stocks that look cheap deserve to
be cheap.
Start with that presumption.
But, there are some stocks that look
cheap that don't deserve to be cheap,
and that's what we're looking for, a
mismatch. A stock with a low
price-to-book ratio, a high return on
equity, a low cost of equity, and a high
growth rate. You're saying, "What chance
do I have finding something like that?"
No harm looking.
There are 48,000 companies, right? Maybe
something got missed.
If you come to me with an enterprise
value multiple, EV-to-sales,
here's what I'm going to do. I'm going
to go back to the simplest enterprise
value equation I can think of, a stable
growth enterprise value model. Expected
free cash flow to the firm next year
divided by cost of capital minus the
growth rate.
Again, I'm going to do the algebra.
I'm going to divide both sides of the
equation by sales. And if I do, my
left-hand side becomes EV-to-sales.
My right-hand side, if I divide
after-tax operating income by sales,
becomes after-tax operating margin.
And the rest of the variables come out
of my intrinsic valuation. The
EV-to-sales ratio for a company will be
a function of the after-tax operating
margin, the reinvestment rate, the cost
of capital, and the growth rate.
Try it out. Pick any multiple,
EV-to-EBITDA, EV-to-EBIT. It's a It's
the first exercise I do when I look at a
multiple is look at those variables,
because then I know what questions to
ask, what to control for.
Now, of course, stable growth dividend
discount models are easy to work with.
That's why I'm going to start The
algebra is easy.
And in fact, if I wanted to get PE
ratios, I said they're a function of
payout, cost of equity, and growth rate,
you can see the process play out. PE
ratios, equity multiple, there's the
Gordon growth model.
Divide both sides by earnings per share,
you get PE ratio on the left-hand side.
Dividends divided by earnings is your
payout ratio.
The PE ratio for a company is a function
of the payout ratio, the cost of equity,
and the growth rate.
You're saying, "What if companies don't
pay out dividends?" Doesn't matter. You
can replace dividends with free cash
flow to equity and get an analogous
equation using a free cash flow to
equity payout ratio. But, it's a simple
device for figuring out what the
variables are that drive a multiple.
I don't know how strong your algebra is.
Mine is
weak to weaker.
And I stay with stable growth models,
because it's simple equation.
You're saying, "What if I have a high
growth company? What if I want to find
out what the PE ratio should be for an
Nvidia?"
How would I do this?
The next page is going to look
intimidating, but don't let it
intimidate you.
Let's say I have a high growth company.
In a spreadsheet, how do we value high
growth companies?
You want to try? What do you What do we
do when we value high growth companies?
Estimate the cash flows during the high
growth period, and at some point we
stop, and we estimate a terminal value,
right? In a spreadsheet, this takes 10
rows. Could I mathematically take a high
growth company and express it in an
equation? I think so. Let's keep it
simple. Let's make it a two-stage
dividend discount model, where there's
high growth for the next 10 years. At
the end of 10 years, your company is a
stable growth company.
This equation basically is a present
equation. The first term in that
equation is a present value of a growing
annuity. That's the dividends for the
next 10 years growing at 25% a year. The
second term in the equation is the
present value of the terminal value.
All I've done is taken what we put in a
spreadsheet and put it in equation.
When I wrote my first book, it was
reviewed by somebody in Barron's. He
said, "I like the book, but it's full of
obscure mathematical equations."
And he was talking about this equation.
We're in deep trouble when present value
equations have become obscure
mathematical equations.
But that's what we reap when we put the
PV button on the calculator. I'll wager
that if I ran a uh uh
quiz two right now in the next 2 minutes
to write out the present value equation
for an annuity,
most of you would not be able to write
it out because you hit the payment
button, the present value. But when was
the last time you actually wrote it out?
Or actually entered it from scratch.
This is the present value of dividends
during the high growth phase, the first
term, and the present value of the
terminal price. Again, I'm going to use
it to get a PE ratio for a company. I'm
going to divide both sides of the
equation by earnings per share, and if I
do that, I get the PE ratio for a high
growth firm, and magic happens. You know
the PE ratio of a high growth firm is
determined by its payout ratio, its cost
of equity, and its growth rate. Sound
familiar? That's what I had for a stable
growth firm. The only difference is I
now estimate them twice, once for the
high growth firm period, and once for
when they become a mature company. What
if you have three stages of growth? Not
a problem. Same three variables,
estimate them three times. This is
incredibly good news,
especially for the algebra challenged,
because it means you don't have ever
have to see this equation. You take the
stable growth model, you do the algebra,
you can come up with the variables that
determine pretty much any multiple.
So, I'm going to use this high growth
model to kind of extract some
information about how markets behave.
Let's say I came to you with a high
growth firm.
I'm going to be explicit. It's going to
have an expected growth rate of 15% a
year for the next 5 years, and 1.5% a
year thereafter.
For the next 5 years, while I'm growing,
my payout ratio is going to be only 25%.
Why? Because I need to reinvest to get
that 15% growth.
I get to stable growth, my payout ratio
jumps to 92 and 1/2%. Sounds absurdly
high, but remember my growth rate is now
only 1 and 1/2%. So, low growth, high
payout.
For the for the purposes of the
exercise, let's leave the beta at one
for both periods.
Risk-free rate is 1.5%. The equity risk
premium is 5%. So, cost of equity for
the company is going to be 6 and 1/2%
through time.
Let's suppose the question you ask me
is, "What's a fair What's an intrinsic
PE ratio for the company?"
I can actually go into the equation you
saw on the previous page. It's intrinsic
because it's just a two-stage dividend
discount model. And you plug the numbers
in, 25% payout ratio, 15% growth, 6 and
1/2% cost of equity. That's a high
growth period. At the end of the high
growth period, the payout ratio jumps to
92 and 1/2%.
And you put in the new the cost of
equity of 6 and 1/2%. You come up with
the PE ratio of 29.15.
What does that tell me?
If you pay 29.15
times earnings for this company, you're
paying a fair intrinsic value for the
company. And I've got exactly the same
value with the two-stage dividend
discount model.
Which your response should be, "We're
pricing things. Why are we going back to
an intrinsic value model?"
I'm going to use this very simple
hypothetical example to talk about what
ifs.
You're saying, "What if what?" Let's say
you go buy this company with 29.15 times
earnings. That's a high PE, right?
What is it about this company that
justifies a high PE?
It's a high growth company, right?
The lead by the company expecting high
growth, 15% growth,
and you pay 29.15 times earnings.
A day from today I surprise you
as a company. In what way?
I tell you that the growth rate for the
next 5 years is going to be different
from the 15% you expected
when you bought the stock.
A positive surprise if I told you it's
going to be higher. A negative surprise
would be if it's lower. I wanted you to
see what would happen to the PE ratio if
I took that 15% growth, held everything
else constant, and change just that
growth rate from 0% to 30%. So, 0 to 15
are negative surprises. 15 to 30 are
positive surprises.
Even before you show the next table, you
can say give me a sense of direction,
right? As I go from 0% to 30%, what
should happen to my PE ratio?
Should go from low to high.
And that's exactly what shows up in this
table. 0% to 30%. You're saying, "Why
are there five five columns?" I looked
at what would happen to the PE ratio
under five different interest rate
scenarios.
A 0% T-bond rate,
which we got very close to, you know,
briefly in 2020.
A 1.5% T-bond rate, a 3% T-bond rate,
all the way to a 6% T-bond rate. So,
different interest rate levels.
Under every interest rate scenario, as
my growth rate goes up, my PE ratio goes
up as well.
But I want you to focus in on what
happens to the effect on PE of
increasing growth as I go from really
low rates to really high rates. So, as I
go from 0 to 6%, and I change my growth
rate, take a look at what the impact is
on the PE ratio.
At a 0% interest rate,
when my growth goes from 0 to 30%, my PE
goes from 20 to 53.22.
When I have a 6% interest rate, my PE
goes from 12.5 to 28.58.
If my interest rate were 10%, the
difference will become even smaller. The
effect of growth becomes less and less
as I go to higher and higher interest
rates. Why is that intuitive? Really
tell me what's going on.
But played out, why is it affecting high
growth
more?
What is it about growth where the effect
of that yield is greater than on assets
in place? What's the value of growth?
It's all in the future, right? As I keep
raising my risk-free rate, what am I
doing? I'm making the value of growth
less and less.
Let's say you were in Venezuela.
The risk-free rate is 5,000%.
What's the value of growth?
In the It's in the future, but if
risk-free rates are 5,000%, the value of
growth is zero. What if I surprise you
and say I'm going to have double the
growth you thought?
Double of zero is still zero. Half the
growth? Zero.
An earnings surprise in Venezuela will
have almost no effect on the price
because the growth has what? Nothing as
interest rates rise.
As interest rates come down, the reverse
is going to happen. Growth is going to
become a bigger and bigger chunk of
value, and every earnings surprise,
something that causes your growth to get
real, will have a much bigger effect on
your stock price.
You missed a decade. You came in too
late where risk-free rates were at
historic lows.
The US T-bond rate 3 years ago, 2021,
was 1 and 1/2%.
We were in this scenario right here,
right?
Today, where is the T-bond rate?
Closer to 4 and 1/2%.
Holding all else constant, an earnings
surprise today will have a lesser effect
on the stock price than it did 3 years
ago, in both directions, positive as
well as negative.
That's the first thing you can draw out
of it. See, the effect of growth is
going to be different under different
interest rate scenarios.
In fact, you know, in some parts of the
world, interest rates have come come
down fairly dramatically over the last
20 years. You take China.
Risk-free rate was 7, 8, 9, 10% 20 years
ago. Today, it's like 1 and 1/2, 2, 2
and 1/2%.
This is something that's going to play
out. You're going to see much more
volatility in markets, much more
reaction from markets when growth
surprises come out. It's not because
markets are being irrational, it's
because the effect of growth gets
magnified at low interest rates.
Any questions?
Let's take a second what if.
If you remember the original example, I
left the beta at one, right? Just for
simplicity. I could have computed the PE
ratio with betas of 0.75, 0.5, one. So,
basically, the higher the beta becomes,
again, the effect is pretty obvious. At
higher betas,
the PE ratio gets lower for every given
growth rate. Why? Because riskier growth
is worth less than safer growth.
I did look at, you know, five growth
rate scenarios from 5 to 25%. Every
scenario, as I increase risk,
my PE ratio drops off. And take the 25%
growth. That's a high growth rate, but
if I have a beta of 2.5, at a 25% growth
rate, I will be willing to pay only 10
times earnings for the company. Sounds
absurd given the growth rate, but it
vary.
So, I'm going to make you the CEO of a
high growth, high risk company.
So, right now, let's assume you have a
15% growth rate, and um you're, you
know, your beta is two. Your PE ratio is
12.33. You come to me and say, "Look, I
want to increase my PE ratio." What are
the two paths you can adopt to increase
your PE ratio?
Attempt to lower your risk, attempt to
increase the growth rate, right?
You're saying, "Which one's better?"
Depends on where you are in the
spectrum.
And the reason I bring that up is when
you're in a growth company, the focus
becomes growth, growth, still more
growth. Nobody thinks about risk. But
sometimes focusing on reducing risk can
have a much bigger payoff than going for
that extra three or five percent of
growth. To me, that's a thing that
Amazon did that allowed them not just to
survive but become this multi-trillion
dollar company today is what Jeff Bezos
did in 2001.
They'd always been a growth company,
gone after growth, but he was perceptive
enough to realize that risk was coming.
So, he actually turned his focus away
from growth for the moment and he said,
"For the moment, we're going to survive.
We're going to bring risk down. We'll be
able to grow later." And it turned out
to be what it essentially allowed Amazon
to survive the dot-com bust and come
back as the company it is today.
So, it's it's an obvious statement, but
actually allows you to see that
trade-off. Do you want to go for more
growth or less risk? And sometimes the
answer might be less risk is better for
you than more growth.
And finally, I also implicit in my
numbers was an assumption about return
on equity. Where because the payout
ratio and the growth rate put together
gives me a return equity. So, in this
table, I looked at return on equity from
investments ranging from 5% to 25% in
different growth rates. Let's start with
the obvious. For
For the 20 When I have 25% growth,
increasing I'm sorry, 25% return equity,
increasing growth increases my PE ratio.
That's obvious, right?
20%, same effect. 15%, same effect. 10%,
same effect. But you get to a 5% return
equity.
Notice something interesting happening?
When you have a 5% return equity and you
grow at 5
and your growth rate is 5%, your PE
ratio is 13.24.
If I try to pump up the growth to 10%,
my PE ratio actually decreases.
Go to 15%, it gets even lower. And if I
try to grow at 25% a year, my PE the
stock actually becomes worthless.
It's weird, right? I thought higher
growth was better for us. What is it
about
that that example that's leading higher
growth to destroy value? You look past
the So, we'll figure this out together.
What's the value of growth? Remind me
again.
When we talked about growth in the
intrinsic value section,
what drives the value of growth?
Whether you can earn a return that is
greater than your cost of capital,
right? If you earn greater than the cost
of capital, growth is valuable. If you
earn the cost of capital, it's worth
nothing. If you earn less than the cost
of capital, what does growth do?
Destroy value. At a 5% return equity,
remember your cost of equity 6.5%. What
are you doing? You're taking investments
that earn less than your cost of equity.
You go into steroid mode and take even
more investments that earn less than
your cost of equity. You're going to
drive the value of the company
into nothing.
So, when you look at this very
simplistic example, you can see what you
can extract out of it by just playing
what if game. So, you know, I'll send
you the link to the spreadsheet. You can
try different numbers just to get a
sense. It'll give you a sense of what
happens to PE ratios as different
aspects of a company will change.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to play the role of a very naive
analyst. I'm going to put out these
recommendations.
And you now have the ammunition to shoot
me down
based on what you already know about
what drives multiples. Here's my first
try.
Start at 2024, I go collect data on a
bunch of emerging markets. And then I
ask you to take all your money and send
it to Zambia and Kenya.
This is an easy one. What am I missing?
Incredible amounts of risk, right?
So, that was a slam dunk. Clearly, you
don't want to direct your money to the
lowest PE ratio market because God only
knows where they'll land.
Let's make this slightly messier.
It's an example from a long time ago. In
2000, I had collected data on a bunch of
emerging markets and the PE ratios of
these markets.
If I stopped with just the PE ratio,
what's the cheapest market in 2020 in
2000?
Looks like it's Turkey, right? 12 times
earnings.
But I'm now going to give you some
additional information. With each one,
I'm going to pause and ask you on that
variable, what you'd like to see in your
market.
So, in the third column, I give you the
interest rates in each market. So, as an
investor, do you want low interest rates
or high interest rates in your market?
Low interest rates, so
I give you GDP real growth. That tells
you how the economy is growing. So, on
that variable, what do you want? High
high real growth. And last column, I
give you country risk measures. The
higher that number, the riskier you are
as a country. So, there you want low
country risk. Right?
But here's the problem. If you eyeball
the data and try to find those
combinations, you're going to make
yourself dizzy.
Think, "What the heck am I going to do?"
Remember that statistics book you sold
back
or threw into recycling the day the
class was done saying, "Thank you, God,
the class is done. I never have to see
this again."
If your recycling hasn't been empty
since you took that class, go check the
recycling.
If it hasn't, go back to the bookstore
and buy a used version of the book.
Luckily, statistics doesn't have to be
updated. Buy a 2005 version, it's still
the same statistics. I don't know why we
need new editions of statistics books,
to be quite honest.
It's the same statistics over and over
again.
But remember that multiple regression
section in statistics? I know you don't.
Act like you do.
What do you do in a multiple regression?
You have a dependent variable you're
trying to explain, and you have a bunch
of independent variables that you think
explain it.
Let's bring this home. Here, what's the
dependent variable and what am I trying
to explain
in this table? Yeah.
PE ratios, right?
What are the variables I'm worried
about? Interest rates, growth, and risk.
I know there are all these statistical
tests I've got to run, linearity, etc.
Let's say I jump the queue
and I run a regression of PE ratios
against those three variables.
Am I guaranteed to get results I like?
No, the data is the data. Luckily,
I got lucky here. Lucky in what sense?
The coefficients all had the right sign.
That's the first piece of luck.
In what sense do they have the right
sign? Higher interest rates lead to
lower PE ratios.
Higher growth in GDP increases PE ratio,
and higher country risk lowers PE ratio.
Don't expect that in every regression
you run. The data is the data. Here,
I should have also reported the
coefficients and T statistics below
because to me and you have to trust me
on this one, this they were
statistically significant.
And the R squared was 73%.
Is that a good R squared?
Statistics classes I think ruin you for
life.
Cuz everything in statistics 95% R
squareds.
You wonder If you have something where
you have a 95% R squared, you're testing
something not worth testing. Like what?
Is there a link between how much you eat
and how much you weigh? Trust me, there
is. I could run an R squared and tell
you that. Is there a link between how
much you drink and what your GPA is?
Probably.
I don't know how strong the link is, but
it's strongly negative. There's some
point at which you don't even know where
you are in the universe.
In finance, you're never going to get
slam dunk regressions. There's enough
noise in the game. 73% In fact, the way
to judge an R squared, you don't ask,
you know, is this a high enough R
squared? When an R squared is low, what
does it mean? The predictions that come
out of this model have a bigger range.
It'll take care of itself.
So, if you get a 27% R squared, it is
what it is. The data is what it does.
Here, the R squared is pretty good. But
what was the exercise I was embarking
on? I wanted to see whether Turkey was
cheap trading at 12 times earnings,
right? Let me go back to the previous
page. 12 times earnings.
How would I use that regression to
answer that question?
I can plug in the 25% interest rate, the
2% growth rate, and the country risk for
Turkey. And if I do that, I get a
predicted PE for Turkey of 13.35.
It's the last column, right there.
What does that tell me? Given the
growth, risk, and country risk of
Turkey, the PE ratio should be 13.35.
It's a conditional expectation.
The number I should be comparing 12 to
is not the PE ratios for other
countries, but I should be comparing the
12 to the 13.35,
which makes Turkey undervalued, but not
by much.
Right? The 12 is lower than the 13.35.
I did this for every market in this
group.
If you take the percentage difference
between the actual PE and the predicted
PE, you're getting a measure of which
markets are most underpriced and which
are overpriced, and you control for
growth, risk, and
growth, risk, and and and interest rates
in that prediction.
You're going to see me pull out the
statistics tool over and over in this
pricing section because statistics No,
pricing is not about finance. It's It's
really about statistics.
In fact, if I had my druthers, every
statistics class would be taught with
pricing data.
Because it's incredibly powerful,
incredibly useful to see the effects.
Yes.
Outside the range. So, that's the nice
thing about having a regression package
is you can ask for ranges on the
predictions, look for stock. You don't
want to make the ranges too
too powerful because then nothing will
fall outside the range, so you might
have to draw a parameter where you say,
"This is the level at which I would buy
the stock." But you are looking for
things that fall outside the range.
That's why I said, "Don't worry about
the R squared cuz it'll take care of
itself in that range."
Yes.
Because, you know, because interest
rates become a proxy also for infla-
because it is a proxy for what the PE
ratio should be in that market, because
it's an opportunity cost. Right?
Remember that when I raise the
T-bond rate even in my hypothetical
example, the PE ratios dropped off. So,
higher interest rates push down PE
ratios because that becomes an
opportunity cost.
You could bring in the return So, that's
actually a good question. If I wanted to
capture the return in equity in these
companies, I could take a return in
equity. But, in fact, on my webpage, I
have the multiples by country and also
have returns in equity growth rates. So,
if you want to run this regression
across 120 countries, the data is there.
The one thing I can promise you is the
R-squared is not going to be 73% because
you have some small markets and big
markets, liquid markets, illiquid
markets.
But, the data The data is there and the
statistical tools help you control for
differences.
Take another place where I see a lot of
statistical misuse.
Now, every day you open up the paper and
there's somebody arguing that the US
equities are in a bubble. And that's
been happening for 12 years.
And often, and I I don't have an issue
with people claiming in a bubble, but
often the people who claim US equities
in a bubble base it on one very simple
statistic. You know what it is?
That the PE ratio for US stocks now
is higher than it's been historically.
That's the That's the entire basis for
the bubble.
Let's start with what part of that
statement is true. Our PE ratio started
2025 towards the upper end of where PE
ratios have been in the US. Absolutely.
Started 2025, PE ratio for the US was at
20 Then, this is the aggregated PE ratio
for all US equities was at 24.15.
And if you look across time, that's
higher than it's been historically.
So, if I were a bubbler, that's it. I'm
done. Stocks are expensive because PE
ratios today are higher than they were
historically.
Let me pause right there, though. Play
devil's advocate. What else can explain
why PE ratios today might be higher than
historically?
No, no. They were real concern. Bullish
counter is is an intrinsic So, it's got
to be
One is it could be more growth than
historically. I'm not saying any of
these explains it. One, it could be
higher growth. Second,
So, maybe that shows up as lower risk
converted.
With third,
maybe the return on equity of US
companies is higher than it was. And in
fact, it is. Today, the average return
equity for the S&P 500 is 18%. It used
to be 12%. I'm not saying any of these
explain it away, but unless you bring
those in, how can you complete the
story?
You're saying, what are these other PEs?
People finesse the PE, claim it's
incredibly new measure. This is version
called a normalized PE. What do you do
in a normalized PE? So, instead of
taking the price per share now and
dividing by the earnings per share in
the most recent period, they take the
average earnings over the last 5 years.
Why would you do that? Cuz you're saying
earnings can go up and down. I don't
want to use last year's earnings.
And then you have a Shiller PE. What is
a Shiller PE? They say, "Well, the
earnings from 5 years ago,
you might have to inflation adjust
because they're worth more today. So,
the Shiller PE is just a normalized PE
with an inflation adjustment. The reason
I wouldn't even waste my time on any of
these variants is they all move
together.
There's not a whole lot of it I mean,
take a look at how they move. What the
heck are you gaining by finessing,
averaging,
inflation adjusting the numbers? But, I
guess it makes people feel special.
In the last two columns, I've actually
added a T-bond PE. You're saying, what?
PE? PE?
How do you compute a PE ratio for a
T-bond?
Let's say the T-bond rate is 4%.
What's the PE for a T-bond?
It's 1 over 0.04. It's 25. You're
saying, why the heck are you computing a
T-bond PE? Because in the last decade,
what drove me crazy was people looking
at PE ratios
saying they were higher than the past
and not factoring in a very important
add-on, which is
T-bond rates are now down at 2%, 3%. And
investing is a game of where are you
going to go if you take your money out
of stocks? And if you take your money
out of stocks, guess what? You were
investing in T-bonds and paying a 50
times earnings. I would rather pay 25
times earnings for stocks and 50 times
earnings for T-bonds.
So, this was my way of bringing that in
and saying, before we jump to a
conclusion, that's now got receded to
the background. Now, the T-bond rates
are up at 4 and 1/2%.
Fact, it took Shiller a while to catch
on that T-bond rates were this So, he
actually in 2021 finally came around and
said, "You know what? Stocks might not
be overpriced once you control for
T-bond rate." My response is, "Where
were you for the last decade?"
So, here's what I'd like to do. I want
to answer question, are US equities now
overpriced? And I want to go beyond just
comparing PE ratios across time. So, to
do this,
I'm going to actually invert the PE
ratio.
If you invert the PE ratio, earnings
price is called the earnings yield.
You can see what the And this actually
shows you the alternative, T-bond rates
versus the
No.
I've inverted the T-bond rate. So,
earnings yield See this red
line? That is the earnings to price
ratio for US stocks. I took the PE ratio
from two charts ago and invert
And I've also superimposed two other
lines.
The green is the T-bond rate.
So, I have the earnings to price ratio
and the T-bond rate. The purple is the
difference between the T-bond rate and
the three-month T-bill rate.
So, what am I measuring with that now
with that difference?
When I take the T-bond rate and compare
the subtract out the three-month T-bill
rate, what am I capturing?
Capturing the slope of the yield curve,
right? That number is zero, I have a
flat yield curve.
If that number is negative, I have a
downward slope You're saying, who cares?
Why Why does it matter, Sophia?
That could be, but there's actually a
People usually use the yield curve to
actually signal something even bigger
than just inflation differences. When In
fact, when yield curves that are
downward sloping, CNBC is filled with
talk of something for a couple years.
Recession.
Historically in the US, the perspective
of you have a downward sloping yield
curve,
I mean, I've written a piece about how
that approach stopped working about 15
years ago, but for a long time, a
downward sloping yield curve was viewed
as a pre- precursor, almost a definite
precursor. In fact, at the start of
2023, that's why people assumed there
will be a recession cuz the yield curve
has become downward sloping. So, what
I'm capturing with that variable is
actually a measure of economic growth
expectation. That number is a big
positive number, people are expecting
the economy to grow positively. When
it's a flat
zero or downward sloping, people's
expectations for real growth
are much worse.
Now, let me stop with these two lines.
The the the earnings yield and the Do
the two team seem to move together?
When T-bond rates go up, earnings to
price ratios go up. When T-bond rates go
down, earnings to price ratios go down.
Fact, I ran a correlation across
earnings yield, T-bond rates, and the
T-bond minus T-bill. And no surprise,
earnings yields and T-bond rates
have a correlation of about 0.69.
The two move together. Intuitively, that
makes sense. Higher interest rates,
lower PE ratios or higher earnings to
price ratios.
But, I wanted to go further. I wanted to
come up with a way of
answering the question, are stocks
overpriced or underpriced today?
So, I ran a regression.
So, by now, you're going to see me pull
this regression trick out every single
time I have variables to control for.
I'm trying to explain where This is
called a time series regression as
opposed to the cross-country regression.
So, basically, it's looking across time.
I ran the regression of earnings to
price ratios for US stocks against the
T-bond rate and the T-bond rate minus
the T-bill rate.
The R-squared was about 47%.
But, I also want to look at each of the
coefficients and tell and see what it
did. What is the intercept on this
regression term here?
0.0341.
Kind of a starting point, right?
Basically, that's the base across this
period from which I'm going to build
off.
Beyond that, I wouldn't read too much
into it. So, if you have zero T-bond
rates and a completely flat yield curve
where everything is 0%, you can actually
argue that will be the earnings price
ratio. But, you know, you almost never
will get that, but that's a starting
point. Every 1% increase in the T-bond
rates does what?
Increases my earnings to price ratio by
0.56%.
I know it's tough in your mind to flip
it, but remember, the earnings to price
ratio goes up, PE ratios come down. So,
if I told you that I think tariffs will
bring inflation and the T-bond rate is
going to go from 4 and 1/2% to 6% over
the next year,
you now have a mechanism for telling me
what will happen to stocks as a
consequence cuz a 1 and 1/2% increase in
the T-bond rate will push up my my
earnings to price ratio by about 0.9%.
Which will cause the PE ratio to drop
pretty substantially. I now have a way
of translating how interest rate effects
will play out in my earnings to price
ratio.
And every 1% increase in the T-bond rate
minus the T-bill rate reduces my
earnings to price ratio.
So, the more upward sloping the yield
curve, the higher the P/E ratio is going
to be.
But, here's the thing about
that coefficient that makes me pause.
See the T statistic on it?
It's pretty much gone to zero.
The slope of the yield curve seems to
have In fact, if I ran this regression,
I'd probably take it out. There's no
point leaving a variable in there with a
T statistic of
.08. Remember, what's a what's a cut-off
threshold for a T statistic when you you
You remember from your statistics?
1.952. So, let's round it up to, you
know, even 1.5. You might be able to get
away with it. .08 definitely is not
significant. When you run regressions
and variables don't make a difference,
best thing to do is take them out. So,
today, if you ask me to predict the
earnings-to-price ratio, I'd probably
take the slope of the yield curve out
because it doesn't seem to matter
anymore.
You're saying, "What do you mean
anymore?" In 2008, when I ran the
regression,
the earnings-to-price the the the slope
of the yield curve mattered a great
deal. More in 2000, I ran the
regression, the T statistic was 2.2.
Something has happened
in US equity markets where the effect of
the yield curve has become less and less
over time.
I I don't know the What do you think
explains Why is the slope of the yield
curve less predictive of the economy now
than it was 20 years ago or 30 years ago
or 40 years ago?
What causes the yield curve to become
downward-sloping? I know mechanically a
short-term rates are high, but how does
that happen? What's the process?
Well, in this case, there's one
particular government entity, I wouldn't
even call quasi-government entity, the
Fed, right?
In historically, we go back in the US,
the way yield curve became
downward-sloping is the Fed would hit
the brakes.
Fed funds rates would shoot up, T-bill
rates would also shoot up because the
Fed At that time, people thought Fed
must know something. Take a look at
1979. Paul Volcker came in as the Fed
chair.
And short-term rates became almost 20%.
Why? Because he wanted to break the
economy, put into a recession because
that's the only way you could kill
inflation.
And it worked, but with significant
cost.
Through much of the 20th century, the
Fed had this power to affect short-term
rates and also send a signal to the
market about the economy. So, when the
Fed acted, people assumed if the Fed is
raising rates, that must mean the
economy is going to slow. If the Fed is
lowering rates, the economy
But, the Fed didn't act very often. They
used to do this once every two or three
years. You didn't even know who the Fed
chair was. You definitely did not know
the name of any of the people on the Fed
board.
They were never on CNBC.
Nobody talked about them.
You think that's changed?
The Fed has become a fixation.
When I go on CNBC, the one condition I
have for for any interviews don't ask me
about the Fed.
Cuz you're not going to like what I
hear. They talk about the Fed
incessantly.
And in many ways, the more they talk
about the Fed, the more the Fed talks
about itself, the more more every Fed
board member gets up there and makes
speeches,
the less effective the Fed seems to have
become. And that's what this regression
is saying.
In fact, I would make this regression
front and center when people talk about
how much more important the Fed is now
than it was 20 years ago. It's actually
less effective cuz it's trying too hard.
And in the process, it's losing that
credibility that led it to affect P/E
ratios 25 years ago.
I know that might be an overstatement,
but I think in many ways, the more the
Fed makes itself the center of
attention, the less
effect it seems to have in markets.
So, today, in September of last year,
what did the Fed do?
It cut rates. What did the rest of rates
do?
They kept going up.
That wouldn't have happened 30 years
ago. You would probably have seen a much
closer connection. So, the more you see
that happen, the more you're getting a
message of the Fed can do whatever it
does, but we have a mind of our own and
we're going to go out and set prices
based on that.
Incidentally, if you plug in the numbers
into this into this regression, what's
the T-bond rate right now?
4.4%, 4.3%, something like that. And the
T-bill rate, I think, is 3.7%. If you
get a chance, plug the numbers in.
Today's numbers. What you would get is a
predicted earnings-to-price ratio for
today.
And I tried this, I think, just a week
ago. It was like my predicted
earnings-to-price ratio was 4.2%.
What do I do next? I invert it. I come
up with a P/E ratio of roughly 19 times
earnings. And then I compare it to the
actual P/E ratio,
which after the drop-off this year is
now around 20 and 1/2, 21.
You say, "Am I worried?" Yeah, stocks
look a little over overpriced. But, this
isn't bubble territory. Bubble territory
is when you're trading at 32 times
earnings and your predicted P/E comes in
at 13. That happened in 2000.
So, again, as with our earlier
discussion of intrinsic value for the
index, there is reason for concern, but
still, when you bring in history,
there's no reason at 21 times earnings
I'm selling everything and heading
for the caves because
at least for the moment, that's not
showing up. Question.
There are lots of things we pay Why why
do we pay attention to Kim Kardashian?
Right? We live in a reality world. The
Fed has become the biggest reality show
in markets. We have I mean, let's face
it. How many hours a day is CNBC on? Is
it 24 hours a day?
Let's face it. You have You have about
15 minutes of substance to talk about
about markets every day. You got to fill
in the remaining 23 hours and 45 minutes
every day.
The Fed is a nice filler. Right?
It's a charitable way of saying it, but
I think we talk about the Fed because we
have nothing else to talk about. We have
just too much time and too little to
talk about. This gives us a way of just,
"What will Jerome Powell do? What's he
wearing? Is he having a bad day? Is he
sneezing?" I don't know. Everything is a
signal. And we can We can spend I've
seen on CNBC people talk an hour about
the mood in which Fed mem- board members
are.
Yeah. So, I think we talk about it
because we need to fill our time. We
makes us feel more in control.
So, that's all I wanted to say about P/E
ratios. Now you know as much about P/E
ratios as I do. So, in that sense, you
know, let the data So, ask the right
questions. When people say stocks are
expensive, so with Indian equities.
If you want to see if 31. whatever times
earnings is too high, what do we need to
do? We need to bring in the higher
growth. We need to bring in the return
on equity with Indian companies and say,
"Given the higher growth and the India
story, what should the P/E ratio be?" I
can almost guarantee you're not going to
get up to 31.
Probably going to get to 25, 26. And
then you're really stretching to get to
31.
But, that's just my gut instinct. The
data needs to kind of answer that
question.
So, the problem with P/E ratios is you
divide price by earnings, you're going
to get a number. And if your rule is I
won't buy stocks which have high P/E
ratios, you're almost never going to buy
high-growth companies, right?
That was actually the challenge that a
guy called Peter Lynch faced in 1970
when he was made the put in charge of
the Fidelity Magellan Fund.
Fidelity Magellan was the first growth
mutual fund in the US of any magnitude.
Before that, there were mutual funds
where you invest in all equities.
Fidelity Magellan was just growth
stocks. Peter Lynch was put in charge.
He said, "Go buy growth companies." And
he started with the P/E ratio because
that was the only metric around. And he
said, "I can't find any stocks
because if you tell me to buy stocks
with a P/E ratio less than 20 or less
than 15, there's nothing in my growth
universe that gets there
because these are high-growth companies
that trade at high P/E ratios." Do you
see a escape hatch here? If you can
somehow bring growth into your metric,
then maybe you can find a way to buy
high-growth companies.
Peter Lynch did not invent it, but his
books were a big part of what's called
the PEG ratio. The PEG ratio, what do
you do? You take the P/E ratio and you
divide it by the expected growth rate.
So, let's say you have a stock with a
P/E ratio of 30. By itself, it looks
high, right? But, let's say the stock
has a growth rate of 50% a year.
30 / 50 gives you a .6 PEG ratio.
That might be much better than a stock
trading at 15 times earnings with a 5%
growth rate.
PEG ratios become the shorthand that
analysts use to
find growth companies that they think
are cheap.
In fact, there's a whole area in
investment philosophy called GARP,
growth at a reasonable price.
Right?
And PEG ratios are their primary
instrument. They go around looking for
stocks that trade at low PEG ratios. I
don't like PEG ratios. They have
horrifically bad
valuation properties. To see why,
let me try to extract what the variables
are that drive PEG ratios because when
people use PEG ratios, what are they
saying? Don't worry about growth, I've
already brought it into the multiple,
right? Let's see if that's true. When I
do the determinants of PEG ratios, does
growth drop out of the equation?
So, went back to my original two-stage.
You have to use a two-stage model
because PEG by definition is for high
growth companies. You divide by earnings
and then you divide by growth, you end
up with an equation for the PEG ratio. I
know it looks really messy, but take a
look at the variables that drive the PEG
ratio. There's a payout ratio, there's a
cost of equity.
And there's a growth rate. I thought
growth was supposed to disappear. In
fact, growth is all over the place now.
It's in the numerator.
I've really messed up this process
because I haven't made growth go away.
It's essentially become a much more
complicated relationship.
Again, as an equation, you might miss
this, so let's take that original
example we had with the high growth rate
company
and talk a little bit about when a low
PEG ratio or what drives a low PEG
ratio. First, when you look at that
equation, risk affects PEG ratios.
Higher risk companies will trade at
lower PEG ratios. So, start filing a war
to make for a cheap stock in a PEG ratio
basis. You want low PEG ratios. You want
low risk because high risk explains it
away.
Return on equity also affects PEG
ratios. You want a higher return equity.
But, the relationship between PEG and
growth is a complete mess.
With PE, we knew which direction it
least went, right?
Higher growth led to higher PE, so you
wanted a low PE and a high growth rate.
With PEG ratio, if you ask me, would you
like a low growth rate or a high growth
rate? My answer is I have no idea.
Because as growth changes, the effects
on PEG are unpredictable.
So,
I'm going to go back to my original
example. 15% growth rate company for the
next 5 years, 1 and 1/2% growth
afterwards. The variables remain the
same, but here I'm going to compute an
intrinsic PEG ratio.
And given the numbers that I showed you,
the PEG ratio for this company should be
about 1.94.
That's a fair PEG ratio for the company
given the growth rate, given risk-free
rates, given the cost of equity.
So, what I'm going to do is change one
variable at a time to see what happens
to my PEG ratio, just like I did with
PE.
If I increase the risk of the company,
no surprise my PEG ratios start to go
down. For any given growth rate, at a
higher risk I'll pay a lower PE ratio.
The reason I bring this up is I see
equity research reports on growth
companies, tech companies, where they'll
compute PEG ratio for the company and
compare it to the PEG ratio for the S&P
500 and say, "My company looks cheap.
Its PEG ratio is 0.8. The PEG ratio for
the S&P 500 is 1.2. Go buy the stock."
What's the problem with that comparison?
Your company is risky, the S&P 500 is
average risk.
If you have a higher risk stock, you
should trade at a lower PEG ratio.
I also looked at what would happen to
the PEG ratio as I changed my growth
rate.
And here's where things start to get
messy. As my growth rate increases and
with given different returns on equity,
you can see the effects play out just
like they did with PE ratios.
Low return equity companies, the PEG
ratios can start to decrease as you
increase the growth rate.
But, the relationship between PEG and
growth rate can get really messy at
really high growth rates and at really
low growth rates.
So, if you ask me what a perfect cheap
stock would look like on a PEG ratio
basis, I want a low PEG ratio. That part
is easy. I want low risk, not high risk.
I want a high return equity.
But, on growth,
I'm not sure whether I want a high
growth, a low growth, the middle of the
It's because the relationship is not in
one direction. For a part, it's
negative, part it's positive. That's why
I don't like PEG ratios because if I
can't control for difference in growth,
I don't know which question to ask.
I'm not sure whether I'm getting a cheap
stock or stock that basically captures
this effect.
Okay?
And here you see the effect of as
as risk-free rates go up, what what
happens to PEG ratio?
So, take a look at the 6% risk risk-free
rate. As my growth increases initially,
the PEG ratio decreases, right? And then
you get to a certain growth rate, it
starts going up again.
So, the relationship is negative for a
It's pure math.
Growth and value don't have a linear
relationship. When you start playing
with PEG ratios, you're assuming
linearity. You see what I mean by
linearity? How do you compute a PEG
ratio? You take the PE and divide by the
growth rate.
So, when I double the growth rate, I'm
expecting the PE to double, but it
doesn't. We know from a value
perspective that growth and value don't
move that way.
So, if you run into analysts who use PEG
ratios, listen politely,
but then look for the flaws in the
logic, right? So, when low PEG ratio, is
it because of high risk? Is it because
of low return equity?
But, on growth, I'm not even sure what
question to ask because I'm not sure
which direction it should go.
So, let me summarize the PEG ratio
discussion. One is high risk companies
should trade at lower PEG ratios than
low risk companies. So, if you're doing
PEG ratios with tech companies, compare
them to the PEG ratios of other
companies of equivalent risk.
Second,
if you can have a higher return equity,
I would expect you to trade at a much
higher PEG ratio than if you have a low
return equity.
So, if you have a low return low PEG
ratio, I'm going to check your return
equity to make sure that's not the
reason. On growth, I throw up my hands.
High growth rates, low growth So,
basically, you can have very high PEG
ratios at both extremes. You probably
want a growth rate somewhere in the
middle
in the industry.
It's kind of messy to define because
what that is will vary from industry to
industry.
PE ratios, PEG ratios, talk about book
value multiples. There are two versions
of book value multiples.
The first is price to book, where you
take the market value of equity divided
by the book value of equity.
The second is
enterprise value to invested capital,
where you take the enterprise value and
you divide by book value of equity plus
book value of debt minus cash.
They both compare
what the market is paying for this
company to what the accountant tells you
the company is worth.
And this is one of the oldest value
investing metrics, right? You go back to
Ben Graham's security analysis
or intelligent investor 80 years ago.
One of his screens is, "Look for stocks
that trade at less than book value.
Those are cheap stocks."
It's kind of deeply entrenched in value
investing.
Someone take that head on. Say, "Is that
true when a stock trades at below book
value? Is it cheap?" You You probably
already have the ammunition. When a
stock trades at below book value, it
could be cheap, but we also looked at
what other reasons could cause it to
trade. Could have terrible growth,
horrible return equity.
So, let's
take price to book ratios and look at
what drives the price to book ratio.
Going back to dividend discount model,
divide both sides of the equation by
book value, there's my price to book
ratio
for a stable growth dividend paying
company. Return equity, payout ratio,
cost of equity, growth.
But, I'm actually going to take that
equation
and repl- Remember when we did
sustainable growth, we wrote the growth
as a function of 1 minus the payout
ratio times return equity, retention
ratio times return on equity. If you
plug that in, something very interesting
starts to happen. Basically, it becomes
the price to book ratio equation becomes
the return equity minus the growth rate
in the numerator divided by cost of
equity minus the growth rate in the It's
a very simplistic equation.
But, think of what it tells you. When
will stocks trade at below book value?
When the return equity is less than the
cost of equity. When will they trade at
roughly book value?
When the return equity is expected to be
equal to the cost of equity.
When will they trade at above book
value? When the return equity is much
greater than the cost of equity.
It actually
puts price to book in terms of excess
returns. Are you earning above, about,
or below your cost of equity?
Kind of a lesson we learned with growth,
kind of coming back in pricing again.
And that's the reason I think it makes
sense to spend so much time in intrinsic
value first before you come to pricing.
Cuz by the time you get to pricing, you
kind of get it because you had to deal
with it frankly in intrinsic value. It
just comes in through the back door in
pricing, and now you have the ammunition
to essentially challenge those
calculations.
Now, if you had an enterprise value to
invested capital,
everything looks exactly the same, but
here's what you're going to see as a
different. Instead of return on equity,
you're now going to have return on
capital.
So, cost of equity, you're going to have
cost of capital.
But, it's the exact same process. A
company will trade at an enterprise
value that's above its invested capital
if it earns a return on capital that
exceeds the cost of capital. It'll earn
it rough It'll trade at roughly the
invested capital if the two are the same
and at at a discount if it earns less
than the cost of capital.
Last multiple for today, and then I'll
let you go.
I told you at the start of this class at
the start of this pricing section that
when I first started in markets, EV to
EBITDA multiples were rare.
One in 50 companies.
Today, maybe one in two, one in three
equity research reports are built around
EV to EBITDA multiples. I'll wager It's
a classic investment banking question.
It's about EV to EBITDA multiples.
It's become the banking language to keep
the rest of the world out.
Okay?
What's EV to EBITDA? So, what's an EV to
EBITDA multiple? You're out of the
fraternity.
There are good reasons bad reasons why
EV to EBITDA multiples have become
popular.
Can you give me some good reasons why EV
to EBITDA multiples have displaced price
earnings ratios or
price earnings ratios are probably the
dominant multiple.
First is you don't lose as many
companies, right? Remember with negative
earnings, we lost 3,600 companies with
EBITDA, we lose only about 15. We still
lose companies, but not as many. Fewer
companies have negative EBITDA, so
that's a good reason.
Why Second is with price earnings
ratios, you're looking at an equity
slice of the company. And if a company
takes on a lot of debt, that equity
slice becomes incredibly volatile.
So, you're focusing on the entire
company. So, that's second reason is is
EV to EBITDA captures the operating
characteristics of the company. Any
other good reasons why EV to EBITDA?
Why the debt? Why not I the EV I get.
Why the debt? What Why do you think they
add back the debt?
But it has to be more than that, right?
Because it must mean that if companies
have different depreciation methods,
this kind of cleans up the process
because let's face it, our reporting
books companies can have very different
depreciation methods. So, that might be
it. Yes.
That's the legend, right? At least
analysts say EV to EBITDA I can compare
companies in different leverage. We'll
see that that's not technically quite
true, but that's the hope.
Something that's less affected by car
So, those are good reasons. Any bad
reasons why EV to EBITDA has
become
Yeah.
Carry that forward. So, your EBITDA is
higher, so your EV to EBITDA gives you a
lower number. This is going to sound
completely
insane.
It's easier to sell something when you
have a lower number for whatever metric
you're using than when you have a higher
number.
So, it doesn't matter what the metric
is?
No, because we all have our frames of
reference, right? You know the only
multiple that most people have a frame
of reference on where they know what's
high, what's low?
The P ratio. Whether we like it or not,
we have a rough sense. If I told you to
pay 50 times earnings, you'd say that
sounds high.
Six times earnings, it's a
So, when I say company trades at six
times EBITDA, you know you shouldn't be
doing it because EBITDA is before taxes
and before depreciation. Of course, it
should be a lower number. But your brain
latches on to your frame of reference,
which is P ratio, and says six times
EBITDA looks cheap. It's 15 times
earnings is more typical. I know it
sounds insane, but you can sell some
real dogs using using EV to EBITDA
multiples.
Because person on the other side of the
table is comparing them to P ratios
knowing fully well that they should not
do it.
So, for good reasons and bad reasons,
you have all these different things play
out and EV to EBITDA is now part of the
banking pricing lexicon.
So, what I'd like to start with is to
talk a little bit about at least what is
it that drives EV to EBITDA.
So, there's my It's an enterprise value
multiple. I'm going to follow my
practice. Go to the simplest enterprise
value to intrinsic value model. Let's
keep it, you know, stable growth.
Break out the free cash flow of the firm
in terms of EBITDA. That's purely for
practical purposes. And divide both
sides
by the EBITDA. So, here are the
variables that determine EV to EBITDA
multiples. The first is the cost of
capital.
What do you think the direction there
is? As cost of capital goes up,
my EV to EBITDA is going to go down,
right? Second stop is growth rates. Here
again, higher growth rates, higher EV to
EBITDA.
And then there's a third stop that's
mystifying. I stop and ask you what the
tax rate is.
I never did that with P ratios, right?
Why when I come to EV to EBITDA does tax
rate enter the picture and it and it did
not when I did P ratios? Yeah.
Because net income is already after tax.
You paid a high tax rate, your net
income is low. Here I'm looking at
earnings before interest, taxes, and
depreciation. I know this can't happen,
but let's say you are in a country where
your tax rate is 100%.
What multiple of EBITDA should I pay?
Nothing, because they're going to take
away everything in the first place.
Higher tax rates should lead to lower EV
to EBITDA multiples. And finally,
the reinvestment you need to put in to
get the growth rate will enter the
picture. Why? Because if you're
reinvesting immense amounts to get the
same growth rate, I will pay a lower
multiple of EV to EBITDA
than if you don't.
So, as a final act for today, give me
the your your combination for a cheap
So, I I'm trying to sell you something
based on EV to EBITDA. I'm saying this
stock is cheap, it's trading at or this
company is cheap, it's trading at five
times EV to EBITDA. The first question
you're going to ask me?
What's the cost of capital, right? Maybe
I'm a Venezuelan company.
And I should be trading at two times EV
to EBITDA. So, the cost of capital could
be high. The second is you're going to
ask me what the growth rate in the
company is. Am I growing? Am I stable?
Am I declining?
You should definitely ask me about my
tax rate.
If I have to pay 50% taxes, maybe I
deserve to trade at four times EBITDA.
And you also want to check to see how
much money I'm putting back to get the
growth rate.
Again, common sense checks. And I'm
going to leave you with this. I have no
problem with equity research analysts
pricing companies. I completely
understand that.
What I have a problem with is how sloppy
they are about
checking after they've come up with the
conclusion. So, when you tell me a
company is cheap based on EV to EBITDA,
at least do me the honor of going
through and saying, "Show me that the
tax rate is not the issue, the growth
rate." That you at least check those
numbers.
And most of the time, I don't see that
happening. People are basing it on just
the pricing and say, "This stock is
cheap, this is expensive."
And you have the ammunition now to ask
those follow-up questions to make sure
that something that is cheap is really
cheap rather than deserving to be cheap.
So, I'm going to leave you with that. I
will start with the quiz on Monday.
And
uh you know, watch for the email on
seating arrangement because you have to
go to the right row.
Yeah.
Okay. Well, as long as you ask the right
follow-up questions, it doesn't really
matter which metric you Yeah.
I'm taking